bonjour bonsoir monsieur roy alors il
faut vraiment s'attendre à ce que
plusieurs biens de consommation et un
prix qui augmentent au cours des
prochaines semaines a fait tout ce qu'on
ait porte
par contre là j'ai plein de produits de
consommation des vêtements des meubles
des équipements de jardin et d'opéra ce
sont des produits de consommation
courante qui sont touchés par cette
hausse des coûts de transport tout ce
qui provient des six de chine 9 mm mais
aussi d'europe vont être touchés par ces
coûts de transport comment on explique
cette rareté de couleurs et sap togo
mentation des coûts pour faire
l'importation de débuter avec les ailes
le début une amende et la pandémie la
cog hill 2 en asie en chine où on a eu
10 arrêts de production
pas d'après on envoie prix en chine mais
bon si l'europe était touchée ensuite
l'amérique alors on recevait des
compteurs avec des biens d équipement
des pièces et ses comptes à s'accumuler
l'année par dali cours des
manufacturiers
parce que les entreprises étaient fermés
étaient obligés de cesser leur activité
on s'est donc retrouvé avec un retard
comme s'accumulent de contenu et par le
temps qu'on aurait eu six individus
demain de le problème était déjà grave
de chez les exportateurs les expéditeurs
on était à court de civc compteur ville
pour être capable de remplir id de
réapprovisionner ajouté hertz ensuite en
deuxième partie
l'an dernier une augmentation subite de
la demande des gens comme vous savez
plus voyager piano restaurant alors
soumis à investir dans la rénovation
dans la chaude demeure
dans la narration d'équipement de
jordaniens 6e et beaucoup de ces
produits sont importés alors une hausse
importante de la demande avec une
pénurie de bell dans la capacité
alors si la recette parfaite pour une
augmentation 10 des coûts parce que le
transforme héritiers aussi un des
secteurs où de jeu de l'offre et de la
demande de fonctionne à peu près
parfaitement donc lorsque les capacités
diminuent la demande augmente c'est
qu'il y aura des augmentations et c'est
le consommateur au bout du spectre qui
est qui va payer ces augmentations là où
bout de chaîne logistique et
effectivement c'est le consommateur qui
va en payer une bonne partie on a vu
dans votre reportage que certains
intermédiaires bon pour tenter de
réduire la facture mais sans trop vite
et je peux ajouter c'est pas de se
transformer et il en transports herry on
ne vit que la même chose l'an dernier
les tarifs ont littéralement doublé
parce que encore une fois une baisse
subite de la capacité de transport donc
mais aussi ont cherché à utiliser le
transport et riz ou us travaux minutes
ils ont même genre et quand vous parler
d'augmentations de tarifs augmentations
de coûts on parle de quel ordre
qu'est ce que vous faites donné comme
exemple oui elle est déjà là et ce au
plus on s'en tire assez bien avec une
augmentation 80% des indices qui nous
montrent que ça peut avoir triplés même
qu adopter sur certains marchés
et c'est pas exceptionnel on a vu ça au
début des années 2000 avec elle
la croissance des importations de chine
et d augmenter diminution aussi subite
après un ralentissement économique en
2008 2009 donc il ya beaucoup de
volatilité dans ce marché là on peut
souhaiter que ça va se calmer un peu
puis que lesdites et répond on re re
diminuer avec une augmentation de
capital l'arrivée de nouveaux comptes en
train de fabriquer et de nouveaux na'vi
sk d'autre solution qui sera
envisageable pour les importateurs pour
minimiser justement cette flambée des
prix ouais
fait souvent la possibilité de fabriquer
localement
quand ça peut faire partie de la
solution mais c'est pas nécessairement
une solution pour tout le monde
bien souvent il faut avoir recours à une
automatisation la robotisation pour
réduire les coûts suffisamment et on ne
peut pas des volumes aussi qui permet
d'abaisser les tarifs de production donc
pense qu'on joue on va devoir continuer
de vivre dans une économie mondialisée
et le câlin j'imagine aussi on le répète
beaucoup mais aussi à ce que des
pénuries qui sont à prévoir selon ce que
vous voyez dans votre radar beaucoup de
retard je connais des gens qui attendent
leurs équipements de jardin et puis leur
emploi entre les pays d'autres sont des
électroménagers ainsi suit donc tous les
secteurs peu près sont touchés ça va
finir par arriver mais ça risque d'être
un peu d'air
avez vous une idée approximative le
combien de temps ça pourrait durer tout
ça est très difficile de les voir dit si
comme vous ou sur les ailes je tenais là
la demande si la demande commence à
diminuer parce que les gens commencent à
voyager s'atténuer dans les prochains
mois ou dans les prochaines années
avoir avoir mais entre-temps on va
certainement payer des augmentations
vont parler de laissac humer dans divers
biens de consommation qu'on va retrouver
dans nos entreprises dans nos commerces
jacques roy professeur en gestion des
transports ou hec montréal merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
au revoir